[Music]
hello everyone
welcome and thank you for joining us i'm
isabel hilton and i'll be
moderating this iai debate on passion
action and hypocrisy so from family
feuds to twitter tirades
many people speak passionately about the
need for change and they draw
inspiration from individuals who may
have sacrificed
life or limb to bring about change
yet few act on their beliefs other than
casting a vote from time to time
and many continue to participate in
systems that they publicly condemn
and consider unjust so are we cowards
hypocrites or worse should we accept
that as citizens
we don't have the answers and leave it
to those who are elected to find
solutions
to intractable problems do we have to
recognize that individuals
don't have the capacity to change the
course of history and simply seek
satisfaction and contentment in living
according to our own values
in our own lives or is it the duty of
all citizens to act on our beliefs
and do all we can to change society in
ways that we think
necessary well to debate this i'm joined
by
four distinguished panelists john cessn
is an anarcho-primitivist author and
eco-philosopher whose work focuses on
the effects of civilization and the
urgent need
to return to a free society based on a
hunter-gatherer lifestyle
aaron bastani is co-founder of navarra
media
one of the most influential independent
radical left-wing media organizations in
the united kingdom
he's also author of fully automated
luxury communism which presents his
vision
of 21st century communism emma slade
gave up a high-flying flying career in
finance to become the first western
woman
to be ordained a buddhist nun in bhutan
in 2014.
she's an author and founding ceo of the
charity
opening your heart to bhutan and sir
vince cable
is the former leader of the liberal
democrats who served almost continuously
as an mp
since 1997. he was secretary of state
for business
innovation and skills from 2010 to 2015
during the coalition government
and is equally well known for his
foxtrot on a strictly
christmas special so um
i'm going to ask each of our uh
panelists to
lay out their case if you like um for
two minutes
uh before we get into the debate in a
slightly deeper fashion and the question
that i want each of them to respond to
is should we just accept that as
citizens we don't have the answers
and shouldn't we leave it to those who
are elected to find solutions to
intractable problems
john could i start with you certainly
well i find it encouraging when i think
i'm seeing at least some signs of
seeing the whole business at um the
necessary depth
of the problem the overarching uh
crisis and so we've seen uh
this is the way i would put it very
briefly civilizations come and go
they've risen they've fallen and
i would argue that there's now just one
civilization
a globalized uh totalizing one
under the sign of technology and capital
and it is visibly grandly failing
on every level in every sphere i think
and that's being born in on people not
just in terms of ideas but in terms of
life i think we're in the age of
pandemics where
the epidemics proliferate one after
another and tend to become
pandemics and of course that's where
we're at right now
uh the environmental catastrophe has
been arriving
unfolding the seas are rising they're
acidifying or warming they're full
full of plastics more and more mass
species
uh extinction the weather extremes the
global
air pollution on and on and on that's uh
a monstrous failure of civilization i
think
what drives all this and what if the
social of the soul
well we see a landscape a panorama of
anxiety depression
loneliness uh drug use
high suicide rates etc
uh you know you kind of look in vain to
find that the diamond order has any
answers at all
and so uh i think it's time to get
more serious if we're going to contend
with the
with the gravity of all this
and i think we've seen that uh one
particular part of it is
technology which i think is
to some degree come to fill the vacuum
left by the pretty broadly based
failure of political ideas political
claims and promises i think attract
relatively fewer people
that the massive advertising of
technology
that has the answers for everything it's
going to fix everything
uh you know that's that's certainly
ongoing
okay and it says we're all connected
we're more and more connected
well the fact is we're more and more
disconnected we're more and more
isolated
uh it claims that we're all empowered
via technology well we're more
disempowered so i'm guessing from
that that that you don't think there's
much point in leaving it to those who
are elected
to find solutions to this this landscape
that you
you've set out so we will come back to
these issues but right now i'd like to
go to aaron with the same question if i
may
in a way i'm going to repeat really a
lot of what what john has said
um and i think politics in many ways has
not been more important for for any of
our lives i think you can probably go
back to 1930s to say politics has such
significant for the outcomes of
individual
lives and that's because we're in an era
of crisis
and we talk repeatedly about an economic
crisis climate crisis
political representation so on it
becomes a cliche but i think
if you look at covid19 in particular
it's been described as a
a boomerang coming from the sixth great
extinction and hitting
the human race square and the jewel and
the reason being is that this is the
third novel coronavirus
we've seen this century curved 19 uh
other two are mers and sars and the
reason why we're seeing this accelerate
and there are around three thousand
distinct corona viruses amongst the
planet's bat population
is because of deforestation and because
of species displacement
effectively the whole world is now
adopting fast food and industrial
agriculture
and that means there are going to be as
john has just said there are going to be
many
many many more pandemics we should be
you know incredibly grateful this
doesn't have a fatality rate of
something like ebola
you know if you have a mix of something
like ebola with something which is 40
asymptomatic
you see tens hundreds of millions of
deaths now i'm not saying that to panic
anybody but
it's an important thought experiment
think how bad could this have been
for them for the next time and that's
just one aspect of the climate crisis
another is of course
as john said we've all got micro
particles of plastic in our bodies
uh we are looking at two degrees warming
this century which will mean
uh fresh drinking water for around a
third of the planet will disappear
then you've got attendant without the
economic crisis the background noise
tool of this since 2008 we've not seen
rising living standards now
we'll have some disagreement about that
vince will say well that can be
addressed with a counter cyclical
keynesian stimulus something like john
and myself would say
actually this is kind of the end of the
road for a certain economic model
but in any case you know we've not
really seen this uh
happen in western democracies this
extent again since the 20s since the 30s
and by way of just how much the
ecological crisis is intensifying this
is a remarkable statistic
in three years china is using more
concrete than the united states did for
the whole of the 20th century
in three years so these things are
rapidly building up
and right now the concentrations of co2
in the atmosphere
are far higher than they've been in the
history
of primates and then some so we've been
around
been around 200 to 300 000 years but
right now concentrations of co2 probably
the highest level in several
million years so this idea that if we
adopt a sort of ethical stance take a
step back
i i think in a way that's very
irresponsible to future generations
because
the consequences the aftermath of all
that is coming down the line
very quickly probably probably in our
children's lifetime grandchildren's
lifetime
okay so so problems are too big to step
back from
in other words but um but i'm
i'm not hearing from you um that uh
elected representatives are going to be
those who fix it
emma can i just um go to you please and
just remind you of what the opening
uh the opening inquiry was which was
should we accept that
we don't have the answers and should we
just leave it to those whom we do elect
to find those answers
yes and i think it was to intractable
problems wasn't it we described these
problems in the question as intractable
which i first of all
uh to say i think if we describe a
problem as interactive we might as well
do ourselves so let's imagine they're
not interactable problems and
they're clearly urgent problems what i'm
hearing in john and aaron is this
incredible urgency
of the feeling that time is running out
and i think that speaks to
one of the achilles heels of the human
being which is the
nasty to be very short-termist we are
trained as humans
to deal with something that is
threatening us right now and of course a
lot of the things that aaron and john
are talking about require a vision
which brings the future into now and i
think
neuroscience shows that the human being
is not good at that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you